you're the guy single-handedly
responsible for a transforming day Ina
why we built a system of Crisis medicine
not a Health Care system and we have
been led to believe that this is the
system that's going to bring us to a
state of Optimal Health it's not it's
for Crisis Intervention you want to see
magic things happen in your body test
for what it's deficient in and then just
give it the raw material it needs to do
its job you'll be shocked how well it
performs so first let me tell you four
that you can do that are absolutely free
G Brea so much to talk with you about I
mean you're the guy single-handedly
responsible for a transforming Dana
White we'll talk about that uh but first
I want to talk a little bit about the
background that brings you to where you
are because one of the things you used
to do fascinatingly is predict how long
people are going to live and when
they're going to die can you talk to us
about that a little bit sure I was a you
know mortality expert for uh large life
insurance uh companies and large life
insurance policy IES and what this meant
was we you know we know that everybody
is on an Actuarial curve both of you are
on one I'm on one everybody listening to
this podcast is on one you know if
you're a 34 year old male you have a
life expectancy of x if you're a 25y old
female you have a life expectancy of Y
but the truth is that um when when an
insurance company is getting ready to
put um specific risk on your life 10
million 20 million $50 million worth of
life insurance on a single life uh only
one thing matters um that's how many
more months does that person have left
on Earth and interestingly insurance
companies have data that no other
financial services Enterprise has the
federal government doesn't have it um
you know universities and research
foundations don't have it and that is
that they know the day the date the time
the location and the cause of death for
hundreds of millions of lives and when
you know that specific piece of
information you can pull it back into
that person's records don't forget they
also have medical records on these
people they have blood work they have
some type grean testing they have all of
their medical history they have a blood
test that they've done on their own and
so we take that data and we create
Pathways to predict how soon someone is
going to die and these these predictions
were done you know to the month and I
get a lot of flack about it but the
truth is it's some of the most accurate
science in the world you know I I I've
said many times if the database that I
had access to if that database could
ever see the light of day it would
permanently change the face of humanity
I mean it would upend modern medicine in
a way that would be catastrophic because
we know the trajectory of these
chemicals and synthetics and
pharmaceuticals we know what happens
when people are just missing the basics
in um in nutrition and and
supplementation and we can accurately
predict not only the onset of but the
severity of and how quickly somebody
will succumb to disease or pathology and
you know if you want to know how
accurate they are doing this ju just
look at what happened during the 2008
and 2009 you know Financial Services
crisis we had 364 Banks fail you didn't
have a single life insurance company
fail not one in fact when the credit
services division um derivatives
division of AIG one of the largest life
insurance companies in the world went
South it almost took the entire company
over it was the Life Division that
bailed them out um a valid death claim
in the United States has never failed to
have been paid not once there's not one
valid death claim ever issued On A Life
That's failed to have been paid they're
some of the most solvent institutions in
the world and this is because they're
very good at what they do right no other
financial services Enterprise would take
that level of risk on a single variable
there's no Venture Capital fund no angel
investor you know no hedge fund um no
mutual fund that would take that level
of risk on on just one single variable
so they really have honed in this
science and you know what was astounding
about being in that career was that um
you know as I started to spend more and
more time in that career I I realized a
number of things uh number one that
there were uh it wasn't just data right
there were human beings on the other
side of these spreadsheets um and even
though you get brainwashed into being
told that hey you have nothing to do
with this case you're not responsible
for getting this person into this
condition you're not responsible for
getting them out of this condition at
the end of the day it became very hard
to separate myself from the fact that
there was a human being you know on the
other side of the spreadsheet and had I
just been able to pick up the phone and
call them um I could have materially
changed the trajectory of their life um
I was precluded by law from doing that
even if I saw life-threatening drug
interactions I could not pick up the
phone and warn the patient I couldn't
even pick up the phone and tell the
treating physician and when you're
looking at this voluminous amount of
data so my my job was to basically read
medical records for for 20 years and to
ex ract from the medical record the
pertinent information needed to predict
life expectancy and when you're reading
that voluminous amount of medical
records you start to see patterns um you
see that the the reason why most people
are not living healthier happier longer
more fulfilling lives are because of
what we called modifiable risk factors
you know things that people could change
in their life most of them quite easily
they had to do with basics of activity
basics of nutrition
understanding the human biome to fix you
know anemias vitamin D3 deficiencies
simple nutrient deficiencies that these
people had that were dramatically
reducing their quality of life and
that's why you'll hear me say you know
every chance that I get that um I have
two sayings one is that the presence of
oxygen is the absence of disease um
because we did not study a single
disease ideological pathway not one that
did not have its roots in a lack of
oxygen or was not exac acerbated by a
lack of oxygen everything from
autoimmune diseases to alzheimer's to
dementia um to ADD ADHD OCD manic
depression bipolar all kinds of
conditions type two diabetes and and the
second was that human beings are are not
as sick as we think we are we don't have
pandemics of uh mental illness and
pandemics of um uh you know genetically
inherited disease we have a pandemic of
missing Raw material in the human body
we have nutrient deficiencies that are
leading to the expression of disease in
most cases you know when you deprive the
human body of certain raw materials I
mean pick one vitamin D3 for example you
get the expression of what happens when
you deplete that nutrient right so
compromised immune system we know D3 for
example was uh the second leading cause
of morbidity in covid um deficiency in
D3 is why covid disproportionately
affected minorities not because their
minority status but because the pigment
of their skin which actually drove their
D3 levels down even lower and and so if
if we would go back to the basics put
our faith back in humanity back in
mankind back in what God gave us and
give the body the raw material it needs
to heal itself you would see magic
things happen in this world G I want to
get back to that in a second but first
i'm just so fascinated by this idea of
being able to accurately predict uh
people's life expectancy on an
individual level uh particularly you
know I think I'm pretty sure I have life
insurance and and the the information
you'd get about me would be like my age
uh my sex the fact that I broke my arm
playing basketball a few years ago and
that's sort of probably about it how on
Earth can you predict how long I'm going
to live based on things as basic as that
so I I worked in the jumbo Life Division
you're not going to get a life insurance
policy over $5 million of face value
without them sending a nurse out to your
house and doing a blood draw without
them getting all of your demographic
information you're trust um you know
your trusts Wills your divorce decree if
you were divorced um your banking
information your um all of your health
records as far back as they can go
usually five to 10 years and and then a
specific blood test before the policy is
incepted so you can go online and get a
Term Policy for a million dollars and
and submit some basic information that
wasn't the life insurance Division I
worked in I worked in the division of um
uh whole life and Universal Life
policies these are policies that are
meant to be carried all the way to term
um not like a term life insurance policy
98% of term policies never pay a death
claim only 2% of term policies actually
result in a death claim so you could go
on right now to any number of websites
and say I need a $100,000 10-year term
life policy and they're not going to
send a nurse to your house and they're
not going to do an a deep dive into your
um medical records because they know
there's a 98% chance that that Term
Policy policy will lapse because at the
end of that 5 year or 10 year or 20e
term that policy goes to zero it's
usually meant to cover the bread winner
during the um during the formative years
maybe you know um maybe a mother or
father that's the working one the other
one's home with the kids and and if you
lost that income it would be
catastrophic and it needs to be replaced
but 15 20 years down the road that
insurance policy is no longer needed
when you talk about big whole life big
Universal Life policies 5 million 10
million 25 50 million in face value
which is a lot more common than you
think um and these are the policies
where they are predicting um life
expectancy to the month and they're or
using a thirdparty life expectancy
company and they're very accurate with
the data in the medical exra does that
make sense so what are some of the like
key takeaways that that you would be
looking for what is the thing that you'd
be like oh that's definitely telling me
some really useful information I'm
looking for this this is going to have a
material impact like what are some of
the the basics
um so a lot of the basics were medical
misdiagnosis um um chronic conditions
that were left untreated so for example
we would see over and over and over
again we know for example from a n uh
from a uh 2016 Harvard University study
and then a repeated study by John
Hopkins in 2019 that medical error is
the third leading cause of death wow
remember one killer of human beings
worldwide is cardiovascular disease the
number two killer is cancer the number
three killer is medicine it's a medical
era you're welcome to look that study up
um the 2016 study pegged it as the third
leading cause of death the 2019 study it
got worse so they published the 2016
study and buried the 2019 study um but
you know take for example a common thing
that I would see in the medical record
somebody comes in with a long-term
clinical deficiency in vitamin D3 the
sunshine vitamin which which I would
argue is the single most important
nutrient in the human body right it's
the only vitamin that a human being
makes on our own um there's scantly a
single cell in the entire human body
that lacks a receptor for this nutrient
it acts like a hormone sometimes it acts
like a vitamin we make it from sunlight
and cholesterol um I mean just just
think for a second if the human body
only makes a single vitamin out of the
hundreds of vitamins in your bloodstream
how important should that do you think
that nutrient is to human function well
50% of the world is clinically deficient
in this nutrient um 85% of dark
complected populations African-Americans
Latinos Middle Eastern populations are
clinically deficient in this nutrient
and very often when you deplete vitamin
D3 Cola calciferol simple nutrient the
human body you get the expression of
other conditions and I can't even tell
you how many times more times than I
could count um a patient with a
long-term clinical deficiency in vitamin
D3 would go into their primary care
physician and say listen doc I I wake up
sore and achy in the morning like like
I've had a workout the night before when
I haven't the soles of my feet my ankles
are sore when I get out of bed to walk
to the bathroom first thing in the
morning you know now my hips and my
knees hurt and lately it's it's actually
hard to make a really tight Fist and and
uh the primary care dooses um because of
the parallel of that symptoms to
something called rheumatoid arthritis
Primary Care got goes you know what
you've got rheumatoid arthritis I'm
going to hit you with some hyos
prednizone you're going to feel a lot
better and then I'm going to put you on
something called a
corticosteroid and this is just an oral
capsule you're going to take it every
day and your joints aren't a and the
truth is that um once you started
corticosteroids we knew in the mortality
space from Decades of research that you
had six years and one day until you were
having a joint replacement it was so
accurate that I would if you were
60-year-old female misdiagnosed with
rheumatoid and you started
corticosteroids I would artificially
Advance your age six years and one day
and I would begin to reduce what's
called your ambulatory profile how well
you move how well you ambulate and we
know now that sitting is the name of
smoking right sedentary lifestyle is the
leading cause of all cause mortality
right so more sedentary we become the
faster we're going to die and I can give
you the root cause of that but um you
know we we we we just don't move much
anymore and so and this is why I I also
say that aging is the aggressive pursuit
of
comfort Society we we so aggressively
pursue comfort that we accelerate our
aging right we have to stop telling
Grandma not to go outside it's too hot
not to go outside it's too cold just to
lay down just to relax to eat at the
very first Pang of hunger this is
collapsing all of our natural defense
mechanisms but if we go back to this D3
deficiency and um you advance their age
six years in one day you schedule the
joint replacement you start to reduce
the way that this patient ambulates how
mobile they are and now once I reduce
ambulation I can bring in all of the
diseases that exacerbate with reduced
Mobility right all of the cardiovascular
conditions that exacerbate all the
muscle atrophy something called
sarcopenia which is age related muscle
wasting and I can accelerate your
Decline and I can bring diseases forward
from your future into your present most
likely that you never would have had so
if you rewind this scenario you were
diagnosed with a condition that you did
not have you were put on a medication
that you did not need which caused you
to have a joint replacement that wasn't
required which reduced your um Mobility
unnecessarily and brought diseases from
your future into your present and you
died from a condition you never should
have had because you were diagnosed with
a disease that you didn't have put on a
medication that wasn't required and had
a surgery that was unnecessary and this
happens way more often than you think
and as soon as we would see that we call
these anchor diagnosis because as soon
as you are diagnosed with a disease or a
condition rheumatoid manic depression
bipolar ADD ADHD type 2 diabetes high
blood pressure hypothyroid as soon as
you're diagnosed with any of these
conditions it's anchored in the record
and every physician that treats you from
that day forward just carries forward
that diagnosis they don't go back and
say hey I wonder if this physician
pulled set rates and rheumatoid factors
and I wonder if they actually did the
right testing to determine if this
condition existed no they accept that
diagnosis and they pull forward from
there once you're hypertensive you're
always treated as a hypertensive patient
once you're rheumatoid you're always
treated as a rheumatoid patient once
you're Crohn's disease autoimmune you're
always treated treated as Cron's disease
autoimmune and we found aity of
understanding in the um of what these
chemicals and synthetics and
pharmaceuticals would do I mean we knew
that opiates had an addictive ameloid
long before you ever heard of the pain
addiction crisis right we we knew that
patients weren't off of this why because
we had all of their medical records and
we could see that they were going to the
VA and going to a primary and going
cross state lines to another doctor and
getting pain medication and they clearly
had an addiction and and then we would
give them very little chance of getting
off of that addiction or we would walk
them onto other addictions pain
medication is a rich man's addiction
heroin is a poor man's addiction and so
Gary C can I just stop you there look
what you're saying is fascinating and
heartbreaking at the same time because
you're describing a system that whilst
well intentioned is making people even
more sick no question so so I guess my
question is how can this be allowed to
happen and in a society which is as
litigious as a United States how come
there haven't been thousands of lawsuits
because of this well there have been
thousands of lawsuits I mean there are
multi-billion dollar class action
payouts every single year go um you know
watch the um uh documentary on the Opia
crisis nobody was criminally charged um
but billions of dollars were paid out
but if you make $18 billion on a drug
and you settle a $2 and a half billion
dollar lawsuit understand that profits
are not clawed back fines are inflicted
and so there's a there's a um there's a
certain amount of legal reserve for
every single one of these um you know um
you know Pharmaceuticals and again I'm
not attacking big Pharma and I am not
attacking you know the government and
saying there's a conspiracy theory to
kill us but we built a system of Crisis
medicine not a Health Care system and we
have been led to believe that this is
the system that's going to bring us to a
state of Optimal Health it's not it's
for Crisis Intervention I mean if I hit
a windshield at 20 miles an hour 30
miles an hour I'm going to the ER I want
a surgeon I want pain medication I want
the if I get pain in my should you know
uh radiating down my art I'm going to
the emergency room I'm not anti-modern
medicine but what I'm saying is putting
a state of Optimal Health for human
beings in the hands of modern medicine
which is where it is now is a very poor
choice right I mean I I remember when um
uh I was in grad school and I was
getting my second biology degree this
one in human biology and and I had to
take all these plant botney courses and
you know I hated them but you have to
take them and um so I'm there studying
plants and and the one thing that kept
striking me was that it does not matter
what goes wrong in the leaf or the
branch or the trunk of a tree or brush
shru if you call a true Bist or true
arborist out to your house they won't
touch the leaves that are rotting in the
top of the tree they will cortest the
soil and then they'll look at the soil
and they'll say you know what there's no
nitrogen in this soil and they'll add
nitrogen and the leaf will heal and
we've stopped thinking about human
beings this way right we've lost all
faith in mankind and humanity and we we
we don't look for nutrient deficiencies
in human beings we assume that diseases
are genetically inherited and in many
cases that is patently false the
majority of diseases we call genetic
inherited are not disease passing from
generation to generation it is an
inability for the body to refine a raw
material for example taking folic acid
and turning it into the form the body
uses called methyl foli you inherit
genetic deficiencies in a metabolic
process called
methylation which leads to those
diseases you didn't inherit hypertension
in most cases you didn't inherit a gene
that gave you hypothyroid you didn't
inherit a gene that gave you hyper
cholesterolemia hyperinsulinemia
hypertension depression anxiety you
inherited an inability from your
ancestor to refine a raw material this
caused a deficiency which led to that
condition and these deficiencies can be
fixed and so this is this is the the
entire point right I mean if if if if
that tree were truly diseased you'd have
to send somebody up to lad and start
cutting off the branches and trimming
the leaves and skinning the trunk but
the truth is there was nothing wrong
with the tree it was deficient in raw
material and human beings have become
super deficient in basic raw materials
our food supply is is hyper depleted now
because the what we put into the soil um
our water supply has fluoride chlorine
glyphosphate
microplastics um it has uh you know
Pharmaceuticals these get into the body
and they disrupt the metabol ISM of the
body it's it's you know a lot of what I
preach about is just getting back to the
basics you know meat is attacked um the
truth is most meat is very very healthy
for you if it's grass-fed and grass
finished but the when we industrial
raised cattle on corn syrup and and
soybean uh powder which they're never
eating naturally in nature of course the
meat fills with plus and we get a
disproportionate ratio of omega-6 to
omega-3 and we're putting inflammatory
compounds back in the human body and so
what was fascinating to me was that you
know I wanted to pick up the phone and
call those patients be like hey you
don't have lator arthritis just take
some vitamin D3 and get off the
methotraxate um because this is
impairing your ability to absorb other
nutrients and the first thing that would
happen is the consequences of these
medications we knew for example you know
back to corticosteroids you take a
cortical steroid it shuts your gut down
soon as you shut your gut down you
reduce the nutrients you absorb and you
reduce the nutrients you absorb you
compromise the immune system you
compromise the immune system and
nutrients you have a problem with cell
walls cell membranes and hormones now
you're hormone deficient you're not
exchanging um um and eliminating waste
through the cell wall like you were
anymore inflammation starts to rise in
the body and now this Myriad of
condition shows up a few years down the
road that you never would have had had
you just put the right raw material back
into the human
body I'll get you back to the interview
in a minute but first let me recommend a
product that we use all day every day at
trigonometry Towers look going online
without expressvpn is like using your
smartphone without a protective case
most of the time you'll probably be fine
but all it takes is one accidental drop
onto solid concrete to make you wish
you'd protected yourself every time you
connect to an unencrypted Network in
cafes hotels or airports anyone on the
same network can gain access to your
data I'm talking with your passwords
find fincial details the lot and it
doesn't take much technical knowledge to
hack someone a smart 12-year-old could
do it hackers can make up to $1,000 per
person selling personal info on the
darkart web a grand why am I not doing
that expressvpn helps to keep you safe
by creating a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that hackers can't steal your sensitive
data it's super secure it' take a hacker
with a supercomputer over a billion
years to get past expressvpn's
encryption it's also dead easy to use
fire up the app and click one button to
get protected and it works on all
devices phones laptops tablets and more
so you can stay secure on the go we use
expressvpn at trigonometry because it's
a simple easy and effective way to
protect our data and it means I can
watch my feminist websites in peace
secure your online data today and get
three months for free by visiting
expressvpn.com trigger that's e ex P SS
vpn.com SLT trigger and get an extra 3
months free now back to the
show it's very interesting you say that
Gary and what do you say with with
genetic with genes such as the Baraka
Gene which people have isolated and said
you know if you have Baraka one I think
it's your 90% more likely develop breast
cancer if you have Bara 2 I think it's
80% yes so there are genes not not not
all of them there are genes that
predispose you to certain conditions and
there are some genetically inherited
diseases but let me promise you
something 64% of the world's population
does not have hypothyroid 55% of the
world's population is not hypertensive
they don't have the disease hypertension
if you actually look at the categories
of these diseases just take hypertension
for example
85% of all hypertensive diagnosis
meaning diagnosis of high blood pressure
are
idiopathic what's idiopathic mean it
means of Unknown Origin so that means
only
15% of the diagnosis of high blood
pressure we can point to the cause yes
that means 85% of the time we have no
idea what's causing it and what do we do
we medicate the heart we medicate the
heart for a crime it's not committing
the majority of people that have um high
blood pressure have a normal EKG a
normal EEG they have normal heart and
lung sounds they have a normal die
contrast study they have normal cardiac
catheterizations so why are we still
medicating the heart because we're not
looking at the biome we're not looking
at the fact that this this hypertension
that ran in this family because it is
familial meaning genetically runs in the
family does not mean that disease
hypertension is being passed from
generation to generation in rare cases
it is but what it means is that we have
passed a gene
mutation interrupting the ability for
the body to refine a raw material in
most cases it's an amino acid called
homocysteine this is what happened with
Dana White um and if if homocystine
rises in the bloodstream as it's
cruising by the inside lining of the
artery it irritates the artery when you
irritate an artery it clamps down if you
make the pipes smaller in a fixed system
pressure goes up and so now the pressure
is rising but there's nothing wrong with
the heart so we examine the heart
there's nothing wrong and we say we
don't know what causes it and we
medicate the heart so now you're
medicating a perfectly healthy organ
beta blockers calcium channel blockers
diuretics what are these doing they're
stripping nutrients out of the body
potassium magnesium sodium electrolytes
well what needs electrolytes to function
the heart um and so it's it's an
interesting dichotomy of how we're so
myopic when we look very often at
disease some of the worst research ever
done on this planet is when we study
cells or organs in human beings in
isolation right not a single cell in
your body exists in isolation in fact if
you want to cut a a human being's life
expectancy in half any person walking
this Earth no matter what age they are
right now they can be 15 they can be 50
you want to cut their life expectancy in
half put them in isolation you will cut
their life expectancy by fa 50% this is
what happens to cells in isolation you
know they're in an environment where
they're exchanging frequency they're
exchanging electrochemical signals
they're exchanging with their outside
environment they're eliminating waste
they're repairing they're detoxifying
they're dividing and then we pull the
cell out we stick it in a Petri dish and
we do a bunch of stuff to it and we say
whoa this is a magnificent Discovery
look how this cell behaved in the petri
dish then we put the cell back into the
body and nothing of the sort happens and
so what I'm saying is what God gave us
is meant to thrive We Were Meant To Have
It All We Were Meant to have the libido
of a lion we were meant to have sleep
like a bear we were meant to have the
waking energy of a freaking tiger we're
meant to have sharp clear cogntive
function we're meant to sleep deep get a
deep fatal wave of sleep we're meant to
have managed um we're meant to have uh
you know managed emotional state but the
truth is as you begin to deplete
nutrients you get the consequences of
those disease I I I don't think that we
have a a um Mental Health crisis I think
we have a lack of mental
Fitness you know what do you mean by
that Gary what do you mean by a lack of
mental Fitness well what does it mean to
be mentally fit right what is a mood
what is an emotional state right well um
so let's talk about you know brain
chemistry for a minute um if you said to
me what is a mood what is an emotional
state I would tell you that it's a
collection of
neurotransmitters right bound to oxygen
so for example every elevated emotional
state that a human being can experience
requires oxygen as a part of its
molecular structure so for example
passion Elation Joy arousal libido all
the sort of heli one the lottery
emotions all require an elevated
oxidative state so if this is the reason
why no human being has ever woken up
laughing you don't have the oxidative
state to experience laughter but can you
wake up angry yes because anger does not
require oxygen neither does despair
jealousy resentment and so these are
readily accessible emotions so what
happens is our physiology drags us down
into the state where it most comfortably
exists so if you have a low oxidative
state in the blood low red blood cell
count low hemoglobin um your anemic or
even not anemic but you're borderline
anemic your doctor tells you that you're
normal well now you have low levels of
oxygen in the blood you're not going to
reach an elevated emotional state any
for any period of time other than
something that looks like a heart
monitor and you're going to spend your
life journaling and searching and
reading self-help motivational books and
trying to get in the right rooms and
waking up in gratitude and your
emotional state is going to go right
back down to where your physiology drags
it we need data on ourselves in order to
drive a state of Optimal Health you know
most entrepreneurs it's astounding they
know more about their business than they
know about their own blood work um they
know about their own their nutrition I
do this all the time where I'll take
young hard charging successful
entrepreneurs I'll bring them up on
stage and I'll just say hey how um you
know how much money did your business
make last month um you know
$62,400
awesome what were your net revenues
$144,300
um how many employees do you have 16
what's your Revenue employee employee
72,500 just out of curiosity what's your
ose
level um what is your testosterone
though um do you have any idea um what
your insulin level is um do you know
where your D3 stands
blank right that's astounding to me that
we have more data on our business than
we have on our Temple and right so it's
and and the temple is what's driving the
business you know the business isn't
driving the temple and and so um you
know when when when you look at that you
know going back to mental Fitness
um where are these neurotransmitters
made well 90% of them are in your gut
90% of the serotonin the main driver of
mood dopamine the main driver of
behavior is made in the gut we take an
amino acid called tryptophan we
methylate it in the gut into um a
neurotransmitter called serotonin goes
up to the brain creates a move what if
you can't what if you have an impaired
conversion of um tryptophan into
serotonin what if you can't convert
phenol alanine into tyrosine at the
right rate to um dopamine well now you
get the expression of that disease you
know we used to for decades we defined
depression as an inadequate supply of
Serotonin so the the prevailing um
definition in all the modern medicine
was if you're low on serotonin you're by
definition depressed you know not one
SSRI raises serotonin so you would think
if the definition is I have low
serotonin then the fix would be to raise
serotonin but that's that's not what we
do we actually take people that are
depressed we put them on selective
serotonin reuptake Inhibitors these and
what these do effectively not exactly
but effectively they ration what little
serotonin you have so by definition they
never end depression so by definition um
you stay on these longer than than you
should I mean I have clients come in all
the time I'm like how long have you been
on an anti-depressant 15 years 18 years
I go okay well when did you think it was
going to kick
in um but if we understand that these
neurotransmitters that we're trying to
raise are methylated in the gut we
understand that depression rarely begins
in the outside environment same with
anxiety right same with ADD and ADHD you
know me entrepreneurs are are are
hindered by attention deficit disorder
or attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder add is is it's not an attention
deficit at all it's an attention
overload disorder you see in the human
brain we don't just create thought we
also dismantle thought
so if you don't break thought down it's
called catac colomines a a flood of
neurotransmitters in the brain if you
don't break down catacol amines because
you lack B complex of vitamins you lack
methylated B12 and you lack methyl
folate which are the big ones that help
do this um then you are creating thought
at a faster rate then you're breaking it
down and the M becomes clouded people
that have ADD do not the ability to pay
attention they lack the ability to pay
attention to so many things and then we
say well this is an attention deficit
disorder It's actually an attention
overload disorder and then what does
modern medicine say it says well if the
mind is racing then let's put an
amphetamine into the body to race the
central nervous system to match the pace
of the mind this is what riddlin and
adderal and and um viant do right
they're amphetamines so now what happens
you create a non-physiologic response
you build a tolerance you build um a
dependency even worse and now the only
thing that's certain is that the dosage
of that medication is going to go up and
you are um um inhibiting you're not
raising the very neurotransmitter that
the body needs when when our gut is
healthy and when we have the right
methylated vitamins in our body this is
why I think just about everybody should
be taking a good vitamin D3 with K2
supplement you definitely don't have to
take mine Gary Gary this is what I was
going to say so what you just did there
was a very beautiful analysis of the
things that are going wrong the things
that are going wrong in people's bodies
are things that are people that going
wrong in the medical system so what are
the solutions to this how can people
live a better and healthier life and but
Gary by the way before you answer I just
wanted to add because I was about to ask
you the same question that uh what I
said to you before we started which is
there's a lot of people talking about
medicine and how to be healthy and
whatever on the internet but I think one
of the reasons we are so interested in
talking to you is you've worked with a
number of people Dana why being the most
obvious example where you literally see
the transformation and Dana himself has
come out and talked about the difference
it's made in his quality of life as well
so the question is if I'm an ordinary
person listening to this what do I do
how do I find out what are some of the
things that I may want to look out for
as symptoms Etc how do I get to the
place Dana is getting without having his
money yeah so first let me tell you four
things that you can do that are
absolutely free okay and then I'll tell
you four things that you need to do that
are going to cost you next to nothing
right and you don't have to pay me for
this you you can do this on your own you
know first of all one of the things that
we have come to know in the in the
anti-aging and Longevity space
biohacking space bio optimization
whatever you want to call it is that the
further we get from the basics the
sicker we become you uh human beings
Were Meant to spend 85% of our time
Outdoors we spend 97% of our time
indoors now we go from a covered house
to a covered car to a covered garage to
a covered office to a covered mall right
I mean we we we we don't spend much time
Outdoors what do we get from Mother
Nature we get three things from Mother
Nature we get magnetism from the earth
we get oxygen from the air we get light
from the sun you want to change the
entire trajectory of your life put these
four things into your life they will
cost you nothing and you can do them
anywhere number one try to get natural
sunlight touching your skin once a day 6
8 10 minutes is plenty um because we are
photovoltaic beings yes you can go out
and buy a $120,000 red light bed I sell
one but you do not need that $120,000
red light bed to get the photovoltaic
benefits that we can get from Mother
Nature and expose your skin to sunlight
preferably at first light because during
the first 45 minutes of the day there's
no UVA there's no UVB rays there's only
healthy blue light from the sun this
will reset your cortisol receptors it
will reset your melatonin receptors um
and it will start the process of making
vitamin D3 and it's free the second
thing you should learn how to do is um
learn how to do breath work and the
reason why I say this is there are four
minute six minute 8 Minute breath work
routines I have an8 minute breath work
routine I do it
religiously every single day I don't
think in 40 months I've missed a single
day I'll literally miss a commercial
flight to not miss breath work and
because we can reset our Cadian cycle by
within 30 minutes of waking every day
finding a quiet place preferably facing
the sun preferably outside depending on
the weather and doing three rounds of 30
obnoxiously deep breaths with a breath
hold in between what does this do well
since the majority of us are not moving
and we're not breathing we lose these
auxiliary muscles of respiration our
diaphragm doesn't massage our intestines
we don't get oxygen down into the loes
of our lungs so learn to do three rounds
of 30 breaths I follow a whm Hof style
of breath work it's available for free
all over the Internet it will take you
eight minutes you do it every morning
within 30 minutes of waking to tell your
body this is what we do when we wake up
when you change time zones you're doing
it within 30 minutes of waking it will
help reset your circadian rhythm so
expose your skin to sunlight and um do
eight minutes of breath work the third
thing you could do is a few times a week
more often if you can but a minimum
three times a week try to get bare feet
touching Bare Grass soil dirt sand come
in contact with the surf surface of the
Earth earthing and grounding is a very
real thing um it is not mumbo jumbo it
is not a bunch of spiritual nonsense we
discharge into the Earth if you actually
look at human beings um we build up a
charge and it is complete fallacy that
you can change the charge in the human
body by drinking alkaline water that's
the biggest marketing myth ever sold to
the public you cannot change the pH of
the Blood by drinking alkaline water you
can by contacting the surface of the
Earth pH stands for potential hydrogen
it is a charge so if you want to
repolarize the surface of your cells
contact the surface of the Earth you can
also do this by buying an expensive pmf
M they're about five gr you don't need
to do that contact the surface of the
Earth and the third thing I would do is
I would add an ice cold shower for 60
seconds to three minutes once a day the
majority of people are not going to take
this advice because it's uncomfortable
but this routine will take you all of 10
12 minutes to contact the Sur the Earth
expose your skin to sunlight do a round
of breath work take a cold shower you
don't need to buy an expensive cold
plunge you're going to shower today
anyway just turn it as cold as it will
get when you're done and step into that
stream and why do you want to constantly
do this well because the body has a
process called hormesis where it is
stressed and it strengthens in response
one of the worst things we continue to
do is look at stress as being a negative
for human beings if you don't tear a
muscle it will not grow if you don't
load a bone it will not strengthen if
you don't challenge the immune system it
will weaken we are seeing right now the
consequences of a globally weakened
immune system I'm probably gon to lose
50% of your audience on this next
statement because people are like oh
you're political synopen whatever I I
get attacked for it all the time but the
worst thing that we ever did to humanity
and I'm a human biologist was
residential quarantining social
distancing and masking I'm sorry yeah
you've just won over our entire audience
car don't worry about that I I I lose
half my Instagram followers every time I
talk about you know no no we we're we're
very much with you on that one so those
those are four great things and and you
know what it's so interesting to me what
a lot of the stuff you're saying
resonates with some of the stuff that I
just know experientially for example you
talk about the importance of the gut uh
this whole like IR atic medicine is
based entirely on the idea that you
treat the body through food and
nutrition and and and gut health um and
the showers things we've been doing it
for years going to the sauna doing the
cold showers cold plunges in between and
stuff like that uh but I'm going to take
on board all the other stuff that you're
saying because I'd really love to give
this all of this a go you mentioned
there's also some stuff that people uh
don't need to spend a huge amount of
money on but can do as well can you talk
to us about that we'll get you back to
the interview in a minute but first let
me recommend an incredible alternative
to coffee that will give you that all
day energy without the Jitters in a
delicious hot drink mud water is made
with four functional mushrooms don't
make things out of dysfunctional
mushrooms and only a fraction of the
caffeine you'll find in a cup of coffee
so you'll get that natural energy
without the crash each ingredient was
added for a purpose cacao and chai for a
hint of caffeine and hot chocolate like
Flavor Lion Man for f Focus cceps to
promote Natural Energy and both Chara
and RI to support a healthy immune
system is quality stuff and tastes like
cacao and chai had a baby why you'd want
to drink a baby is anyone's guest but
there we are plus it's Whole 30 approved
100% USDA certified organic non-GMO
glutenfree vegan and kosher so not only
does it taste great you can also give it
to your woke mates right now you can
save 20
plus get a free sample of creamer and a
free frur by going to the link in the
description below or heading to
mwr.com
trigonometry that's
mud
wt.com
trigonometry to save $20 on your
subscription and claim your freebies and
now back to the
show yeah so there's three things that
you need to permanently get out of your
life right because these are products of
the Industrial Revolution we were never
meant to come in contact with these
things I I think we just start with the
premise that we have two choices right
we can either filter our environment and
we can filter things before they enter
our body or we can allow our body to be
the filter so for example when I look at
food I I literally look at food and I
say are you going to serve me or are you
going to steal from me because if you're
going to steal from me you're not coming
into the temple I don't care how pretty
your suit is how well you're dressed and
how much you know how good the icing on
the top looks you're if you're going to
steal from me you're not coming in and
it's it's a kind of an easy premise for
me to guide my S because I I I put a
very high value on my energy level so
number one permanently get tap water out
of your life um uh tap water has um
fluoride it has chlorine it has
microplastics it has Pharmaceuticals I'm
talking about here in the United States
and and abroad fluoride is a is a
neurotoxin it is a byproduct it is a
waste product from phosphate fertilizer
manufacturing it's called fluosilicic
acid and we have to discard the
fluorosilicic acid um because if they
kept it in fertilizer it would kill the
seed so now we take this and we dump it
into our Municipal Water Supply and
every time that we drink water we're
getting fluoride we're getting chlorine
in fact if you want to do an Amazing
Experiment at home order a $150 or $1.99
chlorine intesting kit okay and these
are little droppers that you can you
know you take a glass of water you can
um uh put a few drops and if it turns
bright yellow it's got the presence of
chlorine fill up two glasses of water
from your TAP just do this sometime take
two glasses of water from your TAP set
them on the table put your fingers four
of your fingers down into one glass of
water and leave them there for a minute
and take your fingers out and put the
drops in both glasses of water you will
notice one glass of water is full of
chlorine the glass you put your fingers
in has no chlorine why is that because
it went into your skin you see because
our bodies absorb that and so I think
that people should invest in a water
filtration system um I I I think it's
critically important um I use one called
an echo water filtration system um I
also uh use a hydrogenator i hydrogenate
all my water I think it's the best water
you can put in the human body just pour
water into one of these things you hit a
button and it actually starts to make
hydrogen water if you look at the
research on hydrogen water and how it
feeds the gut um and feeds a whole class
of gut bacteria called hydrophiles and
it gets uh improves absorption of
nutrients supplements so the first thing
is get tap water out of your life the
second thing is to get GMO Foods out of
your life if you look at the trajectory
of research right now from 20 2009 to
2023 we are now really begin beginning
to realize the implication of using
genetically modified foods and putting
these into the human body first of all
we didn't genetically modify seeds to
increase the crop yield we didn't
genetically modified seeds to increase
nutrition we genetically modified seeds
to make them resistant to glyphosphate a
poison that is found in Roundup and
insecticides um so it's easy when you're
going through the grocery store this is
part of what I mean about developing
this mentality of filtering things
filter your water before you put it in
filter your food by just understanding
some Basics I'm not going to eat GMO
foods and the third thing is not to
ingest seed oils um again I got I got
Shadow banned all over Instagram for a
big expose that I did on seed oils and I
said listen I never said seed oils were
bad for you I said industrial process
seed oils are bad for you when you take
a canola plant and you put it in a
commercial press and it comes out gummy
and then you degum it with hexan a
neurotoxin and then you heat that
degummed neurotoxic oil to 45 degrees
which turns it rancid and then you um
deodorize it with sodium hydroxide a
known carcinogen and then you bleach it
and bottle it and put it on the shelf
that is one of the most toxic compounds
you can put in the human body it's
increasing the rate of of skin cancers
it's increasing the rate of
atherosclerosis arteriosclerosis it's
doubling the rate of cardiovascular
disease and these are unnatural things
to put in the body so those are three
things that that may add something to
your budget water filtration um um not
getting G you know getting GMO Foods out
of your diet because non GMO is slightly
more expensive and getting seed oils out
of your diet if you want to make it
simple get five oils you can use a
coconut oil a ghee butter a grass-fed
butter or Tallow for cooking and you can
use an extra virgin olive oil for all
your room temperature stuff it's really
all you need um you can do anything with
those five and can you yeah sorry car if
you want to take it to the next level um
this is where you start to get data I
believe that that every human being once
in their lifetime needs to do what's
called a genetic methylation test and
what is this test it's usually a cheek
swab that you send into a laboratory you
can get them all over the place you do
not have to get the test through me um
there's all kinds of great genetic
testing companies out there you do a
cheek swab you send it in when the
results come back this test will tell
you and this will never change you only
do this test once in your life this test
will tell you exactly what your body can
convert into the usable form and what it
can't and then you supplement for that
deficiency I promise you the most magic
things happen in human beings when you
supplement for deficiency and not the
sake of supplement right so many of us
are caught up in whether or not a
supplement is a good supplement CoQ10
John trumer kirkin um ashwagandha nmn
nicotinic acid you know all of these
supplements are great the question is do
you need them what is my body deficient
in because if you hadn't put nitrogen
into the soil of the plant example I
used before everything poach whatever
you put on that soil you know sodium
sulfur calcium the plant wouldn't heal
soon as you give it the missing raw
material that's when magic happens and
you can find that on a genetic
methylation test that way for the rest
of your life you'll never guess again on
what you need to supplement with and
what not here's my something it's right
here you know where are they see I take
a r veratrol i take a um trimethyl
glycine I take a complex of um
methylated multivitamins magnesium and
zinc not much um and it's astounding I
post my blood work to Instagram roughly
every 90 days so I can sh you know kind
of battle the Bro Science Community um
uh and and and just you know put it out
there I have the same blood fat as a
vegan and I get 75% of my caloric intake
from
fat so
Gary what we're talking about here is
revolutionary how can people get a hold
of these particular type of uh tests is
it are there lots of companies that do
it are there very few yeah so you want
to um um especially if you're outside
the US you want to search for something
called a genetic methylation test okay I
specifically look at five genes I look
at
MTHFR it's affectionately called the
[__]
Gene I look at
MTR MTR RR I'm saying these slow so they
can write them down ahcy and C
Mt you will cover such a dramatic
voluminous amount of consequences that
people are chalking up to aging just by
looking at those five genes and
supplement for those deficiencies ADD
ADHD OCD manic depression bipolar your
um very often hypertension not always
hypertension people that have po poor
gut issues anyone with anxiety has to do
that test anyone with depressive history
has to do that test if you have trouble
sleeping chances are you fit into one of
two categories you either lay down to go
to sleep at night and you have a hard
time falling asleep because your mind
keeps you awake because as your
environment quiets your mind wakes up
and and if you talk to people that have
this consequence and you ask them what
are you thinking about they'll say I'm
thinking about the most innocuous little
nonsense like whether or not I got
everything on my you know grocery list
or whether or not I returned that email
or my belt mashed my shoes today um and
or they fall asleep and they wake up
because their mind wakes them up this is
a simple issue with excess catac colines
in the brain as soon as you give the
body the raw materials El methionine Sam
e B complex a complex of B vitamins
methylcobalamin you see that the Mind
calms at night and and now people don't
have a hard time falling asleep because
it wasn't that they weren't tired it's
that their mind was awake and so you
want to see magic things happen in your
body test for what it's deficient in and
then just give it the raw material it
needs to do its job you'll be shocked
how well it performs is this the reason
Gary why so many people who have got
anxiety and depression
tend to have irritable bow syndrome
exactly the reason why right because
where is 90% of the serotonin in the
body it's in the gut if you don't have
it here you can't have it here first of
all no one ever really defines what
anxiety really is I mean what is anxiety
well anxiety is we know we know how to
define it right we know that it's a fear
of the future it's a general um um it's
like a fight ORF flight feeling but when
we actually delve into anxiety and we
and we ask you know from physiological
standpoint what is it well first of all
um we have to understand that the brain
as sophisticated as we'd like to think
it is it's it's it's really not right
it's the brain is actually very Primal
right you know what the brain cares
about it cares about survival and it's
nasty like it's like the little Kim
Jong-un of dictators sits up there takes
everything for itself right if it wants
calcium it'll leech it from the bones if
it wants amino acids it'll strip it from
lean muscle if it wants sugar it'll
activate a receptor on the back of the
tongue and give you a dope of mean
reward for giving it sugar but when we
talk about anxiety um we also have to
understand that the brain doesn't
understand the difference between
perception and reality so I always use
the example that if you drove home
tonight and you got out of your car and
somebody was standing in front of you
with a knife you would instantly have a
figh ORF flight response right pupils
would dilate your heart rate would
increase your extremities would flood
with blood you start having a fight ORF
flight response Gary we live in London
we're used to it
mate
you'd be like hey brother Put The Knife
Down what do you what do you need here's
here's 10 pounds leave me
alone I have actually heard that the
last time I was in London my buddy told
me not to wear my watch out I go what
can't wear your watch in London La now
London [__] um so but think about this
I'm on the 30th floor of a Condo
building right now right so you could be
sitting you could be laying in my bed in
there and start thinking about getting
eaten by shark
and the chance of a shark getting out of
that o whoops getting out of that ocean
and coming up that elevator are zero but
you can have the exact same response why
is that because the same Cascade of
neurotransmitters that showed up when
that guy was in front of you with a
knife is the one that shows up when you
thought about getting eaten by a shark
so once you understand that you don't
need the presence of a fear to feel fear
you start to understand the Genesis of
anxiet iety so if we take it a step
further what's creating that fear a
class of neurotransmitters called catac
colomines when they rise in the brain
you get the presence of fear you don't
have to be on the 30th floor of a
balcony and walk to the edge you don't
have to be claustrophobic and step on a
crowded elevator you don't have to be
afraid of flights and getting on an
airplane you can be sitting on a podcast
like we are right now and people that
suffer from anxiety could start becoming
overwhelmed with anxiety um and the
worst thing you can do is try to reason
them out of having anxiety you know tell
them there's no reason to feel that way
there's there's nothing wrong with you
there's nothing to be afraid of but at
the end of the day um if we understand
that this is a rise in catacol means and
the basic B complex and El methionine
and methylfolate are what degrade these
catacol meines then why wouldn't we try
putting those raw materials back into
the human body to see if we could
permanently put anxiety in our rear
mirror people don't want it to be that
simple but very often It
is Well I Gary it's really I'm glad I've
seen a couple of you interviews uh but
I'm really glad we had you on to talk
about this stuff because I am genuinely
going to go out and give all of this a
go I've been meaning to for a long time
but um I'm very keen to see how it works
out and uh maybe I'll report back and
see see how it goes as well let's do it
yeah I I'd love to as well Gary
because what you were talking about
particularly when it comes to anxiety is
somebody who has anxiety and ADHD and
you know you do the meditation you work
out you do you know I mean those things
help those coping mechanism yeah they
teach to cope right you're just adding
power to the motor to get through it
we're talking about removing yeah right
yeah so I definitely definitely want to
I'm definitely going to give this a go
absolutely me too me too well uh before
we let before we move on to questions
from our supporters uh on locals and and
elsewhere uh our last question in the in
the main interview is always the same
which is what is the one thing we're not
talking about at the level of our
society that we should be um um the
commonality between all of us you know
um it's it's interesting how much flak I
get when I do posts with certain people
I do a post with Dana white people go
he's an atheist how do you work with him
I do a post with Grant Cardone they're
like he a Scientologist how could you do
a post with Steven Seagal they're like
he's a Putin supporter how could you I
said because I a human being and and I
don't ask for your political or
religious affiliation or anything else
nor do I really care I I see a human
being and there is much more that we
have in common than we have um in in
differences and I think sadly um our
governments are doing a very good job at
pointing out the differences and
dividing us I mean when I was growing up
it used to be okay to be a republican at
a democratic dinner and just talk about
your bu now you can't even be in the
same house um and and I think that's the
first thing and this and the second
thing is um I don't think that we're
talking about basic
nutrition enough anymore what we allow
into our food supply and processed foods
and the amount of um um sugars that we
allow into the human diet and and this
this theory of single dose toxicity
which is horrible we should use
something called cumulative dose
toxicity to determine whether or not
something is poisonous um to me is a
travesty because people uh sadly trust
our government and uh they trust them to
keep them healthy and keep their water
clean and keep their food nutritious and
and none of that is is very true all
right well Gary listen thank you so much
uh head on over with us uh to locals and
Elsewhere for questions with our
supporters let's fire it
up what is the importance of sleep to
General Health brain function weight
[Music]
Etc